all right House Speaker Paul Ryan's
announcement he's not going to seek
re-election has ignited a contest to
replace him between the establishment
wing of the GOP and the more
conservative populist swing now in last
night's angle I said the speaker's
departure is a clear sign that Trump's
vision not Ryan's is the future of the
party and that establishment may finally
be seating the party to the man who took
it from there in the first place
however Ryan claimed today that the more
populous Steve Scalise has conceded the
speakership to the establishment
favorite Kevin McCarthy but that's not
exactly what Scalise said on Fox News
this morning you're standing there in
the room next to your colleague Kevin
McCarthy you two are seen as the
frontrunners for this role would you run
up against him if the option came no and
I've said that before I mean I've never
run against Kevin and wouldn't run
against Kevin why not
it's Kevin McCarthy Lee untouchable that
leaves a lot of wiggle room let's
discuss all of this with someone who
once chaired the GOP party and Ryan's
home state of Wisconsin a good friend of
Ryan's as well former White House chief
of staff
Reince Priebus joins us for an exclusive
interview on the angle I thought you're
gonna be in studio I'm so bummed where
are you what are you not eating well
I've been early flight early flight in
the morning so okay thank you for having
me and I appreciate you letting me do it
remote oh no no problem it's great to
see you
so what are we we're gonna get into you
know this the Comey nonsense in a second
the Comey book because this and we're
now just howling because it's just it's
like people have ties his tie is too
long we're gonna get into that in a
second but tell me about the Ryan - Ryan
departure there's there's some
conversation today I heard that there's
a push to have Ryan leave sooner not
don't don't spend the next six months
with this intrigue about who's gonna
replace him but if you're gonna leave
why not leave now instead of the end of
the year is there any wisdom to that
yeah I don't think so Laura and I think
if you look at what Mark meadow said
today he didn't think so either and I
think that's a really important tell
when people like Mark Walker from this
Study Group and Mark Meadows from the
freedom caucus and people in the middle
are all not saying that I think that
tells you what you need to know I don't
think that's going to happen and I do
think that this is I know it's hard to
believe in politics I think Ryan leaving
and all of the other intrigue is more
coincidental with his timing how long he
wants to serve it's been talked about it
for he's been talking about this
actually four years of you know hanging
it up and spending more time at home and
and and and it was a tough call because
yeah but wait it's about I'm sorry to
interrupt but but rights but it's so
it's not because he's frustrated that
they're gonna go in the minority
Trump's you know they're gonna push to
remove Trump from office it's gonna be a
nightmare for the next year and a half
that you don't think that played into it
at all well no I don't I because I think
that if you run in you win and you have
a say you only have a two vote majority
he can't leave then either because then
what are you going to do you're going to
be the Speaker of the House with a to
vote majority and then put a
congressional seat in play I mean you
really had no other option he could have
run again gotten to the minority and
then resigned but it wouldn't have been
honest to the people that were there so
I don't see any other way when you when
you when you go to pancake breakfast
Laura and I know you you know politics
and you you do all these things too but
when you go to pancake breakfast for 20
years in these little towns that you
represent it is very difficult to ask
people to put up four by eight yard
signs all over the district well knowing
that coming January you're only going to
say I'm out of here and then you have to
go home and live with the people that
you just lied to you just there's just
no way around it
and and I think I'd say privately in
talking to Paul and I know him well and
we talk a lot he is you know what
actually he was having a lot of fun in
getting a lot of the work done and he
and he and he had a lot of fun and he
had a lot of enjoyment out of working
with President Trump I mean it's funny
that he didn't like present from it just
not true I mean certainly they had the
times in the beginning that we're kind
of come and go and hit or miss but once
they got to know each other and once
they start spending time together he
actually was having a good time with
that's nice that's nice I'm glad to hear
it's very hallmark but they do they do
have different views I mean way
different reviews I mean is it the Trump
party now rights or is it wait a second
an immigration I don't think I don't I
an immigration I don't think they had a
different view I mean the President and
Paul Ryan were pretty much lockstep with
it we were exactly I mean on daca
the president the the president went
from eight hundred thousand at one point
to one point eight one point six the
original you've come a long way to Laura
Perry Trump on the campaign trail Paul
Ryan was like uncomfortable every minute
of the day I mean he was just like even
after trick wins the nomination he
didn't give a full-throated endorsement
it was like pulling teeth but look
that's that's crying over spilled milk I
got to ask you about this comedy for
denying that I'm just saying as they got
to know each other they actually worked
well together absolutely do you think
kevin mccarthy gets it you know I know
the president likes him a whole lot but
he also really he really respects Steve
and so I think it's a tough call for the
president I think it's a tough choice
for the people in the house but you know
look I think there is plenty of time for
this and the good news is is that the
the 40 million dollars has already been
put in a bank so everything now that it
the parties bringing in is icing on the
cake and the RNC is also on top of that
crushing the DNC so money is not going
to be the issue
the house the house one to ten chances
we keep the house one being I think it's
a coin flip I think it's four point five
I mean III think it's right around a
coin flip I think the winds at the
Republicans face I think some of the
recent elections you know are pretty you
know pretty scary I think the Wisconsin
outcome is a wake-up call for the party
that they have to triple down on voter
identification turnout
and I think it's time to make sure that
we've got the right candidates on the
ballot and if it's possible to get rid
of some bad candidates we should and we
should put better candidates in their
places candidate is what it is where
it's gonna come down to all right call
me book we're almost out of time but
call me book give me your give me your
thumbnail read on I know you had a few
interactions with call me when you're at
the White House but what's your take I
did I listen I know I've heard all the
conversation you had it was great in the
segment before and I don't disagree with
a lot that was said but the one thing
that I would say that I haven't heard is
how just generally improper it is for
the highest select the highest appointed
law enforcement officer in the country
to then turn around for you know a half
a year later and write a kiss-and-tell
about the president look I mean everyone
has their gripes and I'm sure you know I
could tell you privately a few gripes of
my own but I it's just not a proper
thing to do today especially given he
was the director of the FBI it's one of
those things that you know with him I
actually didn't deal with them all that
much Laura I mean it is sort of a
dubious type of thing where it's just
someone who comes in and out very
carefully very quietly some interactions
in the Situation Room some initial
interactions as you know early in Trump
Tower and other than that there just
really wasn't a whole lot there I mean a
lot more of analyzing made reps made up
of it then actually was rice free was
great to see you and thanks so much for
coming on all right